it's been less than a week since
governor steve sisilak lifted nevada's
mass mandate however masks are still
required at airports on planes on buses
hector mejia reporting live near
downtown las vegas and hector how are
local agencies you know handling this
are they running into any issues
well we came to find out good morning to
you guys we're at the bonneville transit
center where we see a bus right now
taking off you know this is one of the
places where people are still being
asked to wear a mask the regional
transportation commission answered our
question about whether or not passengers
are pushing back in a statement the
agency said they actually have not
experienced an increase in passenger
issues or pushback on wearing masks
while riding rtc buses since the mandate
was lifted last week and we're talking
about the state mandate they are
reminding everyone that similar to other
public transit agencies though across
the country riders are still required to
wear a mask while traveling on rtc buses
or visiting any of their transit
facilities the rtc says they are
following mandates from the federal
transit administration and back in
december was when the tsa extended the
mass mandate through at least march 18th
for all modes of transportation we've
seen that mandate get extended several
times since it first went into effect
reporting live hector mejia live local
now